welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by tony
phoenix coles who is the managing
director of digital gurus
tony entered recruitment straight out of
university after graduating from the
university of leeds and since that
moment she hasn't looked back she's
worked in the industry since 2006 within
that time she's worked for multiple
recruitment brands where she has
consistently accelerated her recruitment
career and progress through the ranks
however since 2011 tony has worked for
the rethink group where she has
progressed from team lead head of
practice and now more recently becoming
the managing director of one of the
recruitment brands within the rethink
group
digital gurus to drive it forward tonya
thank you so much for joining me on the
podcast
oh it's my pleasure and we're looking
forward to chatting with you
likewise so we're recording this a day
after england semis
so uh if eva has a quan on the ball bear
with us
uh good job we're not recording this
yeah good job we're not recording this
uh yeah day after uh sunday on the on
the monday night
so where we always like to start on this
podcast is is really the which i'm i'm
sure it's something that you've thought
a lot about in your career but basically
it's the million-pound question like in
in your opinion what characteristics and
trades do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
okay um so in my experience both
personally and then everyone else that
i've worked with there's a few
key themes that for me are just critical
so
one is um
consistency
absolutely vital um
hard work but working really smartly so
like the first few years of recruitment
by far the hardest you know you get paid
more as the years go on and it gets a
bit easier for you but that's as your
network grows and things start becoming
easier for you so i think
doing things consistently and always
doing what you say you'll do at the time
uh it can be really really small um and
for me like just how either
how organized you are or how much
knowledge you can retain because again
you know there's one ecosystem it's the
the same people and it's the same
markets etc that you're working but as
your knowledge grows
if you start a really solid foundation
and continually just work away at it
improving day by day
then i think it's almost a failure safe
that you're going to be a successful
recruitment consultant
yeah
interesting and then just and then we'll
talk more about this but just interested
the consistency piece that's obviously
something that
yeah
you'd probably find a lot in yeah high
performing recruiters is the question
but like how how do you go about i guess
identifying maybe a precursor to someone
that could be consistent if they haven't
got recruitment experience out of
interest like what types of things would
you look for these people to be
consistent within their life then
for me i always like to see how well
people can deal with like quite complex
situations and it can be anything so
something really complex that they've
learned a musical instrument a different
language different subject or just a
situation that they've been in and if
they're natural
problem solvers always looking for
solutions they think really broadly and
open-mindedly for me that's a really
strong example that they're going to
have the right dates and obviously
there's all the buzzwords yeah so
resilience is critical you know this
industry is really tough um so i look
for examples of where they've evidenced
previous resilience before
tenacity always a buzzword that's there
but again you know don't keep going and
that's why so many people drop out of
recruitment within the first you know 12
months two years probably maximum three
years and then yeah i tend to think if
they're in it longer than three years
they'll probably stay in the industry
yeah yeah that is interesting and then
just because we're we're talking about
it obviously you you graduated
university
uh
obviously and how how many sort of um do
you hire a lot of grads or have you in
the past
a degree is absolutely not necessary for
recruitment in my opinion anyway
yeah yeah sure agreed i guess the
question was
do you like in your personal opinion the
sort of younger people coming through do
you think they have more resilience less
resilience out of interest harsh all my
my younger brothers and sisters it's
hard to say you know you can never be in
anyone else's shoes unless you've been
in their shoes right so yeah as a
stereotype everyone's gonna say they
have it easier of course they are but
i don't i don't subscribe to that every
individual is unique uh that's the
beauty of the world we live in right so
yeah um
yeah i could not put that stereotype on
i'll treat everyone yeah individuality
no i i agree it should obviously you do
see people say that like call it the
snowflake generation or whatever you
want to call it and i was interested
here well you said in like my my view is
i was like on the cusp really i was born
in 1993 and like for me when i think a
resilience of like i have a younger
brother who's four years younger than me
and even below that
like for me resilience like if i had to
go through school and my younger life
like with like all the tools of today
social media particularly these types of
things like let alone get through that
without social media was hard enough you
had to have a bit of resilience
absolutely let alone with social media
to get through that be mentally strong
or like feel good like
i i think yeah it's just a different
type of resilience i think it's just
different challenges
it would have been so hard that'd be so
hard for people to go through that
yeah agreed and i feel like it's our
responsibility to use experience to try
and nurture you know younger people and
what they're coming through in terms of
you know modern day problems that
they'll face and the social media is a
huge one around mental health and
building up that layer of resilience i
mean the world
now is crazy
yeah exactly
and
just on this topic so where where i want
to start obviously
there's a lot here to sort of unpack
really keen to focus on the last couple
of years because i think uh that's
obviously what you're going to be really
excited about what the future may look
like the journey that you've been on but
always like to start at the beginning
i've recently been sort of interviewing
doing like a specific like 10 episode
series focus on like entry-level
recruiters interviewing people that sort
of in their first year two years to
hopefully help people that are entering
or early stages
again with you and how you entered the
world of work like knowing what you know
now what
advice would you give tony graduating
out of leads
like if you were graduating this year
like what advice would you give her out
of interest if you're going into
recruitment
yeah brilliant question i think
um
being really truthful around what the
job entails is the most important thing
so rewind 15 years ago and it was a
story i remember being so excited to
accept this job i hadn't looked for any
other job and that's because i was done
i was pre-closed
you know i was so grateful for this 17
grand a year job i didn't even know i
wanted it i just a friend recommended me
he got a grand for it you know i was
just sold to all the way so i you know i
would never do that i couldn't put
anyone in that situation now because the
reality of it is you're gonna do that
job for 35 40 hours a week you're going
to think about it for x number of hours
more you know
that person's life so um to try and
answer your question
i would say
do you love working with people
it is a true meritocracy so the fact
that you can have a huge amount
of influence on your earnings potential
earnings career but it's also going to
be around who the people are the type of
company that you work for so i think if
you're really
um competitive then you know it's
definitely going to be a rewarding
career but also if you like to see
progression um if you are really
open-minded and also maybe if you're
quite passionate and quite technical
about a particular area because i do
think if you learn a market the best
people for me are the ones that have a
additional interest in that market as
opposed to the market just being the
vehicle of you know that that's their
sphere if you will yeah yeah for sure
yeah and it's really interesting again i
know it's like a buzzword progression
but one of the things that i've been
asking these people is like what what is
it that sort of
what type of recruitment business do
young people actually want to work for
like what actually lights them up what
are they motivated by is it the
opportunity to buy rolexes or go to
ibiza and these types of things and
those things for sure these people will
enjoy and you get that camaraderie and
you make friends and that is definitely
something people want but if that's sort
of what you're leading with i think
you're missing a trick because the real
answer is progression
that's what they want it's progression
and i think that's that's what i think
is great about recruitment and why it's
such a great
career choice and i think uh and i think
that's that's what i think really needs
to change is like it needs to be less of
an accident i think because it can offer
people so many different things where
they can take all of those different
skills into different industries
i feel like we're making some headway
with that because we've had some people
who have hired in the past that have
actually said to me i want to go into
recruitment i've researched it and i was
really surprised at that yeah how they
researched it but i've got a sister and
she's 22.
to go back to your question i think
right how could i i mean i wouldn't try
and sell the recruitment industry to her
because i don't think it would suit her
i don't know
as much but actually i think i hit a
point when i was about 27
um i don't know if this was ego or
anything but all the skills that i'd
acquired in recruitment you know the
real transferable skills being being
confident holding meetings negotiation
etc
um i really felt like i could go out
into the world and almost do any
interview and hold a really successful
interview now obviously i couldn't go
and be a doctor because i didn't have
those qualifications
anything that wasn't very very specific
quality qualifications
i felt recruit myself
all this i backed myself and i think
anybody could do that so if even if
you're not that sure
it's such a rewarding career to develop
you as a person but then you need the
right company don't you that supports
you
at least the right group of peers anyway
yeah and just on this point of like
early on because it's interesting like
you're completely right so one of the
questions that i've been asking them is
like
what has recruitment given you that you
least expected so far and the most
popular answer is confidence and i just
think like how how many people in this
world would love to be more confident in
themselves and i think like there's been
so many cool stories already where
people were like look i wasn't the most
confident person but now i've been in
environment so i'm speaking to people
that are much older than me different
cultures etc and that's giving them like
you said like that sort of and then
that's even like we're talking first two
years first year in and then they feel
like that let alone five seven years
down the track where you've got even
more of these things so i think it's
um amazing so just final point on this
because i was keen to get your thoughts
on it if you've um did you say that that
was your sister did you say to yeah
so the thing that i've noticed i'm keen
to get your thoughts on this something
you may have seen in younger people
perfectionism
is something that i've like really
noticed which i think is
they're putting basically they're
putting themselves under so much
pressure
for things to be perfect right and i
just found that fascinating i don't know
if you've found that if it may be in
your assistant like they're so caught up
on like i've got to get the perfect
first job out of university this has to
go well
and like they're really concerned about
everything like working out and they're
like super young i mean i'm only 28 but
for me it's just like you double down on
experiences rather than perfectionism
but you're not going to know what you
want to do unless you have more
experiences you taste more things you
know
yeah definitely i haven't experienced
that in my
family situation like all my siblings
are younger than me but i can totally
see where you're coming from but i think
that's again the responsibility
um of whoever's interviewing whoever's
going through those processes and maybe
that's kind of the society that we're in
and it might be again attached to social
media yeah it could be yeah yeah it's
comparing seeing your mates have got the
perfect job in line with their degree
and stuff like that stuff instagram
story you know everybody is
you know you got to take it for what it
is
yeah for sure
so
to to wrap this up then like i'm keen to
really because from what i can see from
your journey obviously worked at a few
different companies and then obviously
i've worked through uh rethink for the
longest i'm really keen to unpack that
but like how would you
always interested like how would you
describe your first
like you said it's typically the hardest
right you're building your network
there's so much that you're learning
like how would you describe your first
couple years in recruitment like was it
really difficult like you said like you
didn't really know much about like how
would you describe your first couple
years
really yeah i mean i was uh you know
quite extroverted uh played sports
played in university sports teams so
culturally i worked in an environment it
was an s3 company um and you know it is
brutal i was at my desk every day half
seven because i was the newest you had
to get in to show willing otherwise this
is quite disdain
and then you are the last to leave i
mean i was really lucky i lived about
five minute walk away this was in leeds
from the office and i just thought how
how is anyone else doing this job if
they're traveling half an hour i was
knackered
all day every day
expectations were really high and really
out of my comfort zone cold calling
sounding like absolute wally um but then
also like learning a technical market
you know like
recruitment is recruitment right so we
we place people and hopefully we
understand like the culture of
organizations but actually the
specialisms the real niches within those
roles i did java development at the time
um
i'm not the most tech savvy i certainly
didn't know what java was and i
certainly shouldn't have been on the
phone to
ctos heads of development
trying to just navigate my way through
just talking you know a load of nonsense
really so um
it's really really hard learning
something and and the expectations were
really high so yeah i found it really
tough but i enjoyed it i went out a lot
very sociable
and it got easier but yes
so a couple of things there that i just
want to unpack
so
first one is so you so it seems like the
way you describe that like speaking to
those types of people
not
not really knowing a whole lot like you
just pushed through and maybe had more
of a mentality of like fake it till i
make it sort of thing it seems like
there's no choice
or gets that
yes so okay so this is what i want to
ask you because i'm sure you've seen
that you've seen this turn up in in
people in your time of um leading people
and this is really common so around that
period i think some people can like that
can really paralyze them and
i don't know label it with people like
with imposter syndrome and like use that
really easily but like that's typically
the word that comes up and i've
definitely found this in interviewing
less experienced people where they lit
like the quote that has i found really
funny was like this guy was like
something i really found difficult was
yeah speaking to mds like these really
senior people and two months ago i was
sitting in the library like
preparing for my coursework where it is
you know what i mean so like there is
that like imposter that shows up like
[ __ ] out like should i even be like
who am i to be speaking to this person
and like so how what i don't know what
it seems like you just like just yeah
like you said there's no other choice
but like
what would your advice be to work
through that for other people listening
to this if they've got that showing up
in there early on
yeah me a couple of key themes that are
really like they're part of me and they
work for me and it just took a little
while to have the confidence really so
one is just always be truthful always
because the thing is you can't argue
with the truth it is what it is so
whether you don't like it
unfortunately because it's the truth
you there's never gonna you know you
might have some regrets and all of those
things so you know i'm new to this
industry or i'm new to this market i
haven't been doing this job very long
here's what i'm trying to achieve
i'm trying to i'm gonna help you try and
get a new role and use that to your
advantage you know have started so
somebody else might ring you and they're
going to be hitting kpis are going to be
bringing 20 people i need my first deal
more than anything you look like a great
candidate i'm going to spend all my time
getting you
um to always just be truthful and then
people you know hopefully good people
they will um they'll see through that in
the best possible way and then the other
thing is
recognizing that people are people so
job title or not whoever you are
speaking to is another person they're a
human being we're all born i'd say equal
okay yeah yeah for sure just accepting
that and again you're gonna have loads
of people that haven't got the time for
you and they're a bit rude that's about
them not about you so if you're really
honest from the get-go about why you're
making that phone call or what you're
trying to do that person doesn't like it
that's more than it is you and then you
just move on to this one because not
everybody will be like that and then
you've got those little golden nuggets
and you've just got to take some
celebration from those mini successes
yeah i love that yeah i think yeah
great i own it like you said like just
really own it and just like like you
said there's you can't it's the truth
right so that like own it and then yeah
i i definitely got caught up on that on
a bit on like just especially when
sometimes a lot of recruiters start on
the candidate side they get comfortable
with that they're like right smashing it
now it's loads of candidates and it's
like oh right tony now we need to do
some bd like [ __ ] i've just got used to
speed to candidates
yeah it's mental but the thing is
they're all people no one's trying to
tell you
from a robot to a dog to a person
yeah what's walking from one person to
another so get rid of all the labels in
your head yeah exactly you're completely
right so then the other point was
like you said like you yeah you
literally said like surprised how these
people did it and traveled 30 minutes
and i do think this definitely
contributes as to why
um the turnover can be high in
recruitment it's burnt out and i think a
lot of recruiters can burn out in those
first couple of years because of some of
the things i do feel like
the environment that you described i
would say is less common in today's
market might be wrong yeah
i think i think i would like to think
that most companies like the
expectations of like if i don't show up
at this time i could be fired like i
feel like that's definitely been watered
down for sure but like i don't know
being through that yourself being
involved in shaping cultures yourself
now like i don't know
for i don't know how can we go about
making sure that yeah we're doing more
to keep people in um recruitment in
those early days rather than potentially
grinding them to the hole and they're
burning out you know what i mean like
how why why wasn't you why didn't you
burn out like why was you able to just
power through and
yeah um i probably did burn out a few
times uh but i i did actually consider
leaving the industry a few times i took
a lot of holidays um which helped
because i was doing well so i had more
commission and that's how i spent any
commission i ever got um but again like
for me i just think it's meant like what
are we actually trying to achieve right
all businesses they're trying to achieve
deliverables and output so why is there
so much
interest in times and durations and kpi
i honestly i think it is mental i had
this one lad who worked in our team and
he was just useless in the morning he
hated it he was a graduate he'd probably
been sleeping until two o'clock every
day and he must have been late nowhere
alive four out of five days every week i
thought he left wait though he had so
much talent he's actually gone and done
then
he's now a professional gambler in vegas
right he's always like
it's one of his life long dreams and you
know what he handed in his notice with
me 12 months early he's on a four week
notice because we had such a good
relationship as i hoped
but it was to support him on his dreams
anyway the long and short of it we just
got rid of the hours it was like here's
what i need you to deliver in a week
yeah i don't know when you do it but we
will have to have a conversation now of
course there's downsides to that which
is what if the culture doesn't work the
team aren't all together well the
pandemic and working from home has
proven that that's actually a load of
nonsense we all just have these
ideas didn't we two years ago
yeah yeah
yeah
all right so let's
let's talk a bit about um
so obviously you joined
rethink recruitment in 2011. so by that
by that point you is obviously quite
established like you're being a
recruiter and had you already have you
always done like similar markets
so i've always worked in software
development um yeah but when i'll be
really honest i
still didn't love recruitment that much
even though i'd done it for
uh i think about six years at the time i
only took the job at rethink because it
was in manchester and i've a couple of
things have gone wrong in leeds and i
need a bit of a fresh start
um and actually i said to the ceo at the
time i don't actually love recruitment i
don't value it that much
and i didn't it for me it felt really
transactional everything that i'd ever
done so um and i was just i'm just being
honest because if you're on it like
almost going back to my original point
now he seemed quite taken aback from it
but he accepted that honesty but he rang
me about a week later and said i'm just
not sure you're for us you know because
i need people to like the job so i was
backtracking a bit
um and then everything changed when i
joined this business everything changed
because i started really seeing the
value of the job so like everything that
you say you know everything that you say
to candidates in terms of i want to get
you a really great job one that fulfills
you what you know it's a lot of time you
spend more time at work than anywhere
else and i was like right that's got to
be me i've got to live and breathe what
i'm saying to everybody else and just
the my lens changed how i viewed it and
actually getting people jobs that
satisfied them that made changes in
their family or their choices they were
all the things why i got into
recruitment and i was doing that for the
tech world so it then became really
really satisfying and everything changed
so when you joined that business did you
join azabilla because it says like team
legal management straight away or yeah
billing team leader so uh which was i've
been doing that a little bit in my role
when i was accompanying leeds um but i
mean it's really hard billet billing
manager is definitely in my opinion the
hardest of all yeah
we're gonna talk we're gonna talk about
we're gonna talk about that so like so
just for clarity then so i obviously
joined rethink at that point and so how
many how big was your team that you had
to manage when you joined remember
four people people would you was you
doing a new market at that point then
um no they they also did software
development but then it kind of the
markets have changed a little bit so you
work for some companies where it's very
specific niche and you have to add a
business away or you might get splits
etc whereas it was different at rethink
because if you've kind of gone into a
customer you almost could own that
customer therefore do all the roles with
them
always within technology though it's
been fun yeah always within technology
cool yeah
so then obviously stayed with rethink
for like nearly five years and
progressed ahead of practice cool so
let's just talk a bit about this billing
manager piece then if that's okay for
the next five ten minutes because as you
said it is a
it's definitely like one of the most
challenging and i always hear that
so first question i have for you then
because of the way that you joined this
business
how did you approach leading a team that
didn't know you because normally it's
like
you build well
someone gets a good opportunity you've
gained that respect and it's like oh
tony's got the promotion she's great
get it but like that you've gone into a
position where like no one knows you you
haven't got trust you're gonna have to
establish that like you may even be
doing you might even now be doing a
patch that you haven't quite done before
so like how did you approach that of
interest okay so twofold really um i've
always had the attitude i will i
wouldn't ask anybody to do anything that
i wouldn't do myself so from the get-go
it could be literally anything doing any
kind of awkward calls i was just very
front and center with everything i did
it's really important for me
lead by example show that you're doing
everything um so i cracked on straight
away you know
making phone calls having difficult
conversations always at my desk always
in front of people believe a lot in that
coaching by being around you know that
environment you see a lot of people walk
off doing in rooms doing those phone
calls either because it gives them more
self-confidence or because they don't
want to be heard whereas i just i always
just did everything as it was um in
front of everybody and then the other
thing was just i had a i genuinely
really care about people so getting to
know them finding common ground and just
building relationships so i just did
that quite early and i that comes quite
easily to me so just building some trust
within a team um and then just being
myself as well um
and leading from the front it's got to
be
got it so obviously i know obviously the
the sort of type of leadership role that
maybe been in the last couple years is a
bit different so i guess you could sort
of tie this all together from maybe what
you've learned but
just just keen to to learn really like
so what what i continue to find speaking
to agencies around like what learning
development looks like for them and
things like that like a really common
area which is a quite typical blind spot
is definitely the leadership piece
because of the typical journey the
billing managers will find themselves
like that they'll go on or like it'll be
the top builders that go into management
or whatever right a lot of the time they
won't get any sort of leadership
training or support on that they just
have to
yeah learn the hard way really yeah i
guess if you yeah if you were to
i guess encapsulate a lot of the things
that you've learned maybe into like i
don't know one to three things like if
i'm some because a lot of people that
listen to this will be aspiring leaders
for sure
like when we're sort of finding out um
where people what sort of people's
ultimate goals are for their careers
it's either being a top pillar or they
want to lead a manager team
so like
knowing what you know now
about leadership like
and i'm on that journey at the moment i
don't know what would your advice be for
me like top three things that you think
could have a real impact on me getting
more out of my
leadership approach or being a leader
out of interest
okay um
i think listening is absolutely key so
listening to everything around you um
really listening to your team
taking the time to listen taking the
time to listen to
managers um just the ball you know
anybody that's there because actually a
lot of people in my experience they
haven't done it's very tell-focused
um
i think just just on that sorry to
button but i do want to say it
so i love that you started with that so
are you do you are you familiar with the
brand um gymshark
yes yeah yeah so the reason why i bring
up i brought this up recently but i just
think it's i just think it's it's mint
basically so
i absolutely love
um
ben franklin i just love the yeah i love
the general i just think i just love the
way that he i don't know the way he
comes across big into humility these
types of things but obviously he brought
in the ceo six or seven years ago and
like and now he's just been announced
ceo and yeah been on a few podcasts
recently talking about
why and he said one of the main things
that he learned from the ceo because he
wasn't ready at the time was that people
management piece and the thing that's
really stuck with me around this
listening piece is something that like a
bit of a mantra this guy always says is
like um if you're gonna ask how someone
is and you're not prepared to listen to
the answer then you've got it wrong do
you know what i mean and i love the fact
that you started that listening so like
how many people
managers or leaders will go hey tony how
are you doing today and like you know
they're not listening to your answer or
like don't make the time to listen you
know what i mean
that's the first thing isn't it like
this can all start from actually
listening like compassion listening to
your people
yeah yeah
yeah definitely definitely um i think
like i'm fascinated by like sports teams
and i i've probably got i'd probably use
quite a lot of football analogies
because i like
and my team will be laughing their head
off if i've got this classic one that i
always say like and it's i'm kind of
digressing a little bit now so it's okay
it's okay bring me back in a minute but
um i always say i don't need a team of
number nines i do not need everyone to
be
top billers firing in all the goals
because actually no team has a team of
number nines you've got your james
milner's right yeah
your keeper i mean how important is that
goal so when when you've got this team
and you've like less experienced people
and joining businesses and they're
nervous like how you know i'm so far
away from that top builder and all their
anxieties jump in
no one's asking you no one's asking that
whole team to be top billers everyone
can have an equal level of contribution
by their input so just to remember that
but i have digressed so let's go back to
leadership it's okay so we started with
listening yeah like really make sure you
listen would be your like leadership
advice from what you've taken on your
journey yeah what else comes to mind
and then for me um i think
why i said that was because it's kind of
like i think of how sports managers are
like so for me
being a leader is being part of that
team
so
thinking like in terms of flat hierarchy
everyone is equal okay some people have
more experience some people have more
knowledge everyone is equal so having a
leadership style where you recognize
that that team around you i wouldn't be
anywhere without the people around me my
family unit my work unit so it's
spotting the team around you what what
they're good at and where you can
support them with and where you can
challenge but also acknowledging what
your own ones are
you know and being really open with the
team about that and people you know that
they they empathize with that you know
they have that understanding and i think
you build better relationships with your
team so for me
style um just being human
um and then
if you know for thinking of that
category now of people that are wanting
to become in those leadership roles
yeah um
start starting small so mentoring
somebody offering themselves out don't
wait for somebody to come to you in fact
here's another key one i've
never ever been in a position i've
always just
i call it assume as if
so i will act in that role anyway i've
always done that so i was acting like
the md before i was the md i was acting
as a senior consultant before i was even
told i could be on the gateway to be a
senior consultant
so act as if you know go and assume what
some of those things are
and just evidence them so that when
those individuals move into that
leadership role it's as though they were
already in that
yeah i love that and i've heard that a
lot on here so i guess i just want to
just
just sort of zoom in on that a bit just
that just to hear what you would what
you think like when you say
act as if like how like how do you
actually
do that do you know what i mean so like
let's say i'm listening to this right
now and
i do want to be i do want to be the
director of this business etc like but
i'm at the moment managing a few people
blah blah blah how can i actually go
about showcasing that i'm acting as if i
am that already is it just doing extra
things or like is it a mindset thing
like i don't know how does that actually
for a bit of both so i guess depending
on where you are exactly so if we kind
of work from the top and we'll go down
so if you're trying to get into that
director piece there are things that a
director is expected to know so i think
there needs to be some kind of
self-analysis of where your knowledge is
for example figures right the financials
do i know what a p l looks like do i
even know what ebitda means how does
that get broken down some businesses
will have more knowledge and
transparency around that and others i
mean i've hired people before and
they've never even looked at a p l
because they've just been told do this
number here's what you'll get paid at
the end of it but they've been kind of
treated in this associate director is
what a lot of people said
so
understand what it takes and if you
don't know that you know go and seek out
that information go and find out go and
learn it nothing no one's going to stop
you from learning that information some
businesses are really cagey and wouldn't
give all that information right which is
fair enough go and learn what a p l is
what profit looks like what true profit
is what contribution even means so if
you start talking in that language and
then around the business and your
understanding of it you're going to
elevate your position automatically
i think um
taking on more um so that that can be
anything it's not necessarily doing more
so just taking on more responsibilities
you know
i can't imagine there's a single person
listening to this now that if i said to
them what is wrong with your current
business they couldn't give me an answer
right but don't be a moaner about it go
go and find the solution and then
present those solutions now loads of
people will be sent back saying
no we can't do that we've got this and
those frustrations will come out and
those people might leave and that's a
shame for the business because they're
going to lose good people but yeah go
and answer all the problems that you're
suggesting in your own head or hopefully
not moaning about but probably um find
the solution
and present it yeah
no i really like that i really like that
yeah if you listen to this and you have
an idea of where you want to go then i
think yeah it starts with that self
analysis doesn't it like what if i do
want to be a leader then how are my
leadership skills at the moment it's all
those things and then you can start
there and then go and find that so and
sorry i was just even like one step back
from that if you're a senior consultant
you've never managed anybody before you
know you will you have peer group around
you if you spot someone on the phone or
that they're having a difficult time sit
by their desk with them and just go and
say like i thought that call was
brilliant how did you find it um i
didn't hear all of it could you tell me
a bit more about it and just go and role
model yourself in and around your
environment to show that you're actively
going and mentoring and supporting those
around you
yeah and i really like that and i love
that practicality of like
i love that practicality of like yeah
what what things do you think the
business could do to improve and taking
that off your own back and then trying
to come up with new ideas and things
like that i think that's a great way to
show like what you're about and yeah i
think that's a great thing and then the
other insight that i've taken that which
i think sometimes people miss so you
know you said that you really acted as
if before you as an md was md
how many people around you knew
that
you wanted to be like you wanted to be
where you wanted to be so what what what
i'm trying to allude to is like how many
people did you communicate in tone it's
like hey this is where i want to so you
know this is where i want to get to this
is where i'm heading about how
how much of an impact did that happen is
that something you did i've been trying
yeah i'd say quite a lot of people um
for me it's really important and to be
that transparent with everybody around
you um
because for one they've always got their
own mind
of where they want to get to so you're
always assuming that there might be
leaders in our business now that think
well tony's told me she wants to be the
md for the next three years that means i
now can't be it so i think it's also
really important just to share at the
end of the day there's a lot of growth
um growth in the industry growing the
market right now growth in businesses so
just understanding that there are much
broader opportunities than what that
looks like so for me i would all
waste
talk
about where i was at right now in my
career like in my personal life as well
what things do i want to achieve i
always think talking about it setting
those holds you really accountable also
if people care about you which hopefully
people do work in caring environments
other people like want to get involved
on how they can help get you there and
how you could help and kind of that
exchange of information you know why
open source isn't as good as it has is
everyone's got together and they've made
these slight improvements themselves and
it's a continually improving process
um
yeah and yeah the reason why i bring
that up is because i think again it
comes back to our point of like
not being like if you do want to
progress your career you do want to
accelerate then you can't be like the
best chance you have of doing that is
not being someone that sits there and
waits for it to come to you and i think
that sometimes some
some people can miss that you know like
if i work for your organization and i
know i want to get to this position
i want to make sure the people that are
going to be involved in that decision
know that's something that i want
because the next time they're in some
sort of board meeting or business
decision meeting they're going to go oh
you know what actually i had a
conversation a day whilst i was making a
coffee he shouldn't really wants that
position maybe he's someone that we
could think about do you know what i'm
in so i think you should be proactive
yeah i always have the same statement
nobody can read minds
so again whatever position you're in no
one can read your mind again you hear a
lot of people don't you moaning i i
couldn't get this well did you ask for
it did you actually communicate to
anybody because it's not actually the
employer or you know it's not my boss's
job to always worry about my career it
should absolutely be an element of it
but it's my responsibility it's my
career it's my responsibility
yeah exactly
so
i want to talk to you before we finish i
want to talk to you about the dg journey
uh but before we go into that i want to
segue into
a couple of things so one
uh women in recruitment i want to talk
to you about your journey with that
two i wanna talk to you a bit about yeah
how that then i don't know what's your
journey been in like being um
a woman in a leadership position and the
senior position like how what that
journey has been like
talk a bit about how we can maybe
inspire more women in the industry
uh and then the other thing which i
think is which is part of like what
re-entered me and you to reconnect on on
doing this was then the whole sort of
raising a family and maintaining your
career
peace
um could we start there is that okay
yeah
just so i guess the re the reason why i
wanted to talk to you about it is
because i think
i would actually be appalled at the
amount of like
terrible stories that you would hear
from
like just women wanting to go to raise a
family they've worked that absolute
socks off to get in a great position in
their recruitment career and then like
have to go through like a crazy journey
of like one being terrified to tell
their boss that they're pregnant then
bring another human being into the world
then raising them then like being with
them for loads of time then being
worried about coming back then like and
like that being really difficult
and not being supported by the business
they worked really hard with them being
their lives potentially had a really
great
lady on recently called bernadette who
basically said like she was a contract
recruiter and yeah she like she got
promised things that she didn't get
delivered she got told she's gonna keep
certain things she's gonna get bonuses
but she didn't get them right so i guess
and i'd be
i'd be so confident there'd be so many
stories like that so i think it's just
yeah it's just really important i think
to make sure that um women listen to
this know that like if they have gone
through that it's not like nothing makes
it any better but at least they like so
i guess what what's been your journey
like how how difficult have you found it
to
raise a family maintain your career like
you really strike me as someone that's
clearly being career driven focused
wanting to achieve have have big dreams
so like how have you gone about
maintaining that and maintaining your
career aspirations as well as your
personal family aspirations as well
yeah okay so for me it's always family
first
um it's really tough but you know what
if i didn't have a family you can't tell
me that people who don't have families
also have easy lives again like you just
can't judge anyone until you're in their
shoes so yeah i've had two kids uh in
the last my eldest is three
so
even just like being pregnant you know
was difficult i was really lucky i
didn't have any qualms telling anybody i
think at the time i was a regional
director um just communicated it okay i
did only take six months off so i say
only that was a personal choice of mine
i was really passionate about the brand
like digital gurus hadn't existed in the
north and that was like my baby at the
time so
taking that time out and having my son
it was really weird right so i had a
caesarean which meant it was a planned
caesarean so i worked until the friday
um sorry i worked until the thursday my
cesarean was on the friday wow
i was still emailing everyone in the
still in work mode so that was weird but
that's my personality right so and it
took a little while to kind of switch
off because then the baby is there and
they need you like fully
um and then my second time around my
little girl is now 10 months old so i
took seven months out i was really good
with this i did give myself all the time
off because i think you need these
breaks and these resets so whether you
go off and have a baby or have a
sabbatical or you have a long holiday
like everyone says but if i have a two
week holiday like wow i did actually
switch off on day eight and you're like
right okay
um like life's too short for only
switching off on day eight but it
happens right because the the job is
mental isn't it it's non-stop
it's one job where you will never ever
finish because there's always more you
can do which is kind of what we love
about it as well so i think doing all of
that uh it's been really hard balancing
emotions because yeah i'm quite an
emotional person anyway um but like this
morning classic example football last
night i had a couple of wines i took
both of my children to nursery so um
and they were both upset when i dropped
them at their room we just moved house
so they're in a new nursery so they both
cried as i dropped them off right that
was really hard i'm in the car i then
burst out crying so i'm like then gotta
calm myself down and be like right like
where are the practicalities will they
be all right is the nursery safe will
they be happy yes yes yes
thinking i've got this podcast thing i'm
familiar
i never carry makeup around with me so
that's cool
um and that that's just the reality of
it but for me
i'll just talk about that because again
going back to my original point that is
just what's happened that's not me being
crazy me being emotional that is just
what
happened to
today
if i can't tell like that what's
happening
then what's the point of anything so
yeah yeah it's really hard
i was just gonna say what about
i've heard it i've heard it a couple of
times where
sort of uh people have shared like when
they've come back from eternity their
confidence can be at like an all-time
low like really low work because there's
so many different things going on like
leaving your child for the first time
these things did you experience any of
that like did you have to maybe rebuild
a bit of confidence or
yeah
um it was probably for me less about the
confidence as it was managing extra
stuff like your head is already very
full so when you come into work you're
only talking about work i mean how many
times have we heard in recruitment you
leave your [ __ ] at the front door you're
here to work now like yeah that is the
most bizarre sentence i've ever heard
about because if we were a robot that
might be quite easy however of course
there is a level of professionalism
where you have to try and
compartmentalize things i fully get that
but i think just um
for me it wasn't so much about the
confidence more just the emotions that
go with thinking is my child safe today
are they okay what they're doing and
then things happen like even tonight i
really want to pick my kids up my ceo is
in manchester up from london and we've
got some time together at half four for
me it's really important to have that
time with him if i said to him
um could we move that forward 100
wouldn't care that of course get home to
your kids but actually
i also need a full day my team so it's
just
prioritizing everything and the one
thing that i will say to any female is
regardless of how organized or efficient
you were before and i felt that i really
was it is new levels once you've had a
kid because there's
no crap that doesn't need to be done my
efficiency levels are through the roof
if it's something we're in and gets
talked about it gets done and talked
about because i am leaving at a certain
time it's not like where you're just a
bit late and your partner's pissed off
with you because you're now home late
like my kid needs picking up so i'm
getting all of this done today because
it has to get done today so if anything
i had a bit of an advantage coming back
i would say
yeah i love that
right so let's talk about dg
like last sort of 15 minutes or so let's
talk about the german dg because i know
that you shared with me and i know you
won't mind me saying like obviously
joined
dg when they got acquired by the rethink
group
in 2016 and like you said it was like
your baby because they didn't have a
presence in the north
and that was something that
you obviously took on and was a really
exciting opportunity for you
so like i guess what was keen just to
dig into initially and then we can
finish by like where it's at today how
you sort of navigated things in the last
12 18 months how it's gone how you
thinking about the future but like
obviously with them not having a
presence and it was more down south they
did have a presence with other places
internationally as well
like talk to me about
like what was
i guess what people would be interested
in is like
how did you go about
um expanding this brand up north in the
most effective way ultimately like you
most recruited listeners would have had
to build out some sort of desk from
scratch before build a business like
how did you go about building the dg
branding up north out of interest what
ended up being your strategy and how did
it go
um a lot of prongs to that one was
internally um creating a culture
you know a raw fresh culture which was
very values driven so what are the
values i felt were important and then
communicating those with potential
people to join that so what we did we
built something ourselves and we
harnessed it and it grew and it was just
so real and wonderful and it's continued
to grow with that but it's obviously
adapted as the years have gone on um
but externally in terms of actually even
just having that brand presence
we um at the time so events and
networking wasn't really a massive thing
then like everyone did a thought
leadership something or perhaps a
roundtable
um but i built this group it would call
it digital north and it was just to kind
of use the same word and it was kind of
a privately owned group i private in
that you had to request access to it
which i know goes against a bit what i
was saying before about the open source
element but it was more so to ensure
that the quality was really high right
yeah yeah and what we did we just gave
really really good content and just
shared everything and again just the
truth of everything people like genuine
issues that businesses were having at
that time so really not that dissimilar
to what you're doing but within the tech
space and what we found was it just grew
like next level and if anything digital
north became bigger than digital gurus
no one even really knew till north was a
digital gurus thing
and
we were a team of recruitment
consultants
doing a presence in the north it was it
was amazing you know that the pandemic's
obviously not that because for the last
couple of years but then i was really
fortunate and i was able to get
our board to invest in the office space
in manchester so like most places have
offices and then they've all got like an
event space within their office
whereas i was able to get the money to
flip that on its head so we actually
have an event space that we have desks
in if that makes sense
so
that was game changer because we had so
much flexibility for us i mean to be
honest no one needs the investment to do
that anyone could do that um but i put
more focus and also
how people want to be you know fluidity
they can sit where they want let them
work when they want to work for the sofa
if they want to work from the dining
room table if you want to work from home
what's the big deal let people work
where they feel the best and then
support and encourage around that so
yeah
okay cool got that so that's been so and
then just just trying to make it i guess
just a bit more
practical i guess thing like how how did
that then
i get the um
how that would have i personally i get
how that would have sort of massively
helped you but like how did that then
actually translate into like business
and
you were like was it because you had the
reason to call people when you form
relations that way was it just that you
were just
great relationships yeah a little bit of
all of that but again going back to my
original points whatever's happening for
you right now so what was happening for
me at that time was i had lots of
recruitment experience i was excited by
bringing what was a very reputable brand
up to the north so everybody that i was
speaking to i was just sharing that
story because that is what was happening
right now
people like stories and the the truth
and they you know if it is genuine and
real people like that
so
it wasn't hard to be honest uh you just
got to put in the effort and communicate
it you know you've got to put in loads
of hard work
you're
not communicating anything nobody's
gonna know anything but even just
talking to businesses customers new
clients around what's going on and how
you can help
um it worked for us
okay cool so let's talk about more
recent times then the last yeah let's
just let's just keep it like i guess
pre-covered in like covered world and
how you've gone about growing dg
i um
because i i spoke to and hopefully this
will this will make sense but
try to reach out to a couple of people
and your team to see if there's any
questions they'd love me to ask you
and uh
yeah spo spoke to jay and he mentioned
uh sort of he he thought it'd be
interesting for you to share like why
you've decided to
employ the uh spotify model at dg so i
think the tribe piece which i think i've
seen okay um and what like what why the
benefits or like why you've gone down
that angle so maybe i don't know is that
enough to prefix like i don't know what
maybe things look like before you decide
to go down a path is that does that make
sense maybe talk a bit about that
i guess in my experience something that
i'd always work obviously the reason why
one of the reasons why i love the job so
much is like the whole uk economy is
running for me on technology so any
potential client that we're working with
will have some form of technology and
something i always took extra interest
in there's the tech piece itself but
like i said i'm not that technical so
it's the people that i'm passionate
about the culture and the performance of
how those teams are built but if i saw a
business doing something that i either
really liked or really dislike you know
you use that knowledge that's kind of
how people do navigate you know they
take some of the best bits and hopefully
again with bosses in recruitment the
bosses where they do stuff that you hate
what they do you make sure you never do
that don't you
yeah so um what i noticed was
um
we had loads of successes taking some of
the good stuff from other companies and
i'd seen the spotify engineering model
and as i was just watching it i was like
wow this sounds so like where we are but
also where we want to be so the key
piece in it really is around having
these like small self-organized
autonomous teams
and actually a lot of our success
particularly like in the pandemic it's
crazy how well we've done really and i
feel so fortunate but part of that is
because the teams operate really
autonomously and building these smaller
identities in these smaller teams and
kind of how we've segmented them which
yes it's in tribes squads and chapters
so to align with spotify um it's just
really worked for us so i'm really
passionate about that
um so it's the autonomous pete that this
is really important
and then how how big are the like how
big are these groups typically and then
is it the
so they all have their own niches and
like their own roles
so if i use technology as one technology
is one of our tribes it happens to be
the biggest one so within our test tribe
we have i think we currently have nine
squads so for example cloud is a squad
within our tech tribe
within our tech drive so that each
person within those squads so they might
we might have ten dev consultants
they'll each work in different chapters
so it might be basically different
languages
but then does how that whole dev
function works they kind of share a lot
of ideas but it doesn't mean that they
can't work with other squads and that's
kind of how the spotify model is run as
well so they're very self-optimized
teams but then almost it's not about me
setting standards it's about the teams
understanding what works well for them
sharing that information collaborating a
lot and then almost the de facto
standard becomes the one that works the
best for everybody but it's decided by
the teams
wow so interesting yeah i get that so
you've got obviously
tribes then you've got squads and then
you've got chapters within the squads
yeah yeah
so what about how do you make sure like
how like obviously your position within
that then is to a part of the position
part of what you do is make sure that
everyone is although everyone is sort of
running their own sort of squad and
working what works best for them etc
obviously there's got to be a sort of
golden thread hasn't there of like this
is where we are and this is where we're
heading so how do you tie that in now
because i feel like business owners or
people be thinking about that the way
you describe that as okay well how do
you make sure that we're all aligned on
the same vision and mission like how do
you how have you gone about interweaving
that
so three key things that i
hold by one always higher on the right
values and behaviors so within that you
always know that there is alignment from
the get-go never ever just hire on
financial results like that's an
absolute no um second to that is around
communication i personally don't think
you can communicate too much right so
there is a balance with that but for me
i will regularly say to all staff
members again like no hierarchy here
here's where we're up to hear the
financial results here's what we're
trying to achieve here are the things
that we've messed up on uh here are the
levers here just all that all that
information communicate that really
really regularly
and it can either be a whatsapp to all
dg it can be a group email i've got
actually everyone in the manchester
office tomorrow where we're going to run
a almost like a full day of session with
like different components to it around
like hyper and data analytics et cetera
um
so yeah they're the key things for me
and then just finally um
consistency so whilst you're
communicating a lot
if something's not working that's
absolutely fine but at least then
communicate that we're no longer doing
it because again a massive error for me
was a consultant like oh yeah we did
that again for a few weeks and then that
fell by the wayside and
oh yeah
there's nothing more frustrating so
again like think we do do things and
then they do fold it by the way side but
then just acknowledge it we're no longer
doing this because of xyz or we're gonna
try this now so i think just the
openness to allow the agility is what
people buy into
yeah yeah
two final things before we finish
one
always here obviously recruitment
businesses
struggling to scale and hire for their
own businesses so interested you said
like always always always higher on
values not on their financial track
records so just real quick
what's been your journey or experience
on getting that right in terms of like
how do you actually go about
evaluating someone on your values like
how do you go about that in an interview
process out of interest how's that
evolved yeah how have you got better at
that so
has every person i've hired been exactly
perfect absolutely no of course yeah
and some crazy stories like you wouldn't
even believe what and yeah i've
obviously fallen guilty of believing
somebody and then having the wall pulled
over your eyes and i i'd like to think
i'm a good judge of character but that's
for another day because there's some
really mental stories so i think for me
just getting to know the person you know
over time you you do have you got
instincts but it's for me it's also
important to have database decisions not
necessarily um like gut based decisions
there's got to be a bit of both so get
to know the person question them about
loads of different things you know get
evidence always get references now i've
fallen down i've not got references why
would you not um
from your internal staff which is just
crazy that people don't always do that
and then
um
just
letting other people like never never
meeting someone and assuming that
because you think they're amazing that
everyone's gonna think they're amazing
doesn't matter that i'm the md everybody
that's gonna be related to that person
in the first instance should have an
opinion on them so getting other people
involved it can be anybody within the
business just to create a level of
objectivity
yeah yeah fair enough and then on on the
science piece have you used any do you
use like psychometric testing or
anything like that
yeah i've used plenty of those in my
time i think if you can get a really
good one they're definitely useful but
they should always in my opinion just
kind of be complementary as opposed to
yeah like add to like how you're
thinking about things or yeah okay and
then the final point and then we can end
on like
yeah how were like how things are
looking for dg and where where uh you
guys are heading but just just obviously
you said that like really fortunate that
as a business you've performed well the
question really is like why why do you
think you and the team have been able to
thrive uh during i'm sure there's been
challenges obviously along the way but
like overall looking back now as we sort
of really start to come out the other
side that you are in a positive position
why do you think that is i think partly
due to the hiring strategy so that the
team that is currently in dg and that
has been all the way throughout the
pandemic they're they are nice people
they are nice genuine people they've got
everyone else to do well it's not just
about themselves so our collaboration is
off the charts every time you will hear
somebody sharing or doing something and
that that's really genuine and that's
ingrained as part of our culture um so i
think that's been a key thing but then
also you know it does take time to build
high performance and also a strong
culture so i think we just we benefited
from a couple of years previous where we
were almost aligning ourselves to here's
what we're building on here's where
we're trying to get people to some
people really you know we've had like
loads of personal best but again it's
because we've got a group of people who
again going back to my original point i
said earlier the solutions providers so
we've all been faced with the problem um
so it's how can we try and create a
solution to the problem that we're in
which could just be there are less jobs
you know no one's spending people
getting rid of people
it's finding the solutions around all
the granular stuff and that's what we've
been able to translate into what they've
been the many successes that has
contributed to an overall success
love it final question then obviously
was
made md in april this year
so like what does the future hold next
five ten years like what's the what's
the vision like obviously
from the dg's point of view from your
point of view how would you describe the
future
uh well the future lots and lots of
growth
in everything so growth of the people
growth of the staff where they're going
to go on their own personal journeys
growth of customers and clients growth
on the top line on the bottom line which
is where we all want to be growth of
markets growth of offices so i'm just
really excited about all of that um yeah
and then for me yeah i want to take it
all the way so i've got one more job
title ahead of me so the ceo knows that
i want that what you actually what
you're in a
bci yeah i think so i love that
yeah
um and you know and the reason why i say
i think so is that's not right now so
yeah
in two three four years whatever it may
be if i'm in position and i want that
then hopefully i'll put myself in a
strong position and acquired any
additional skills i need now to be
successful in that another comments here
tony's been an absolute pleasure thank
you so much
no thank you so much